c'était le 30 septembre 93 les neuf
juges de la cour suprême du canada
décidé à cinq voix contre quatre de
maintenir le statu quo face au suicide
assisté
un revers pour sue rodriguez une femme
de la colombie britannique atteinte de
la sclérose latérale amyotrophique mieux
connu sous le nom de la maladie de lou
gehrig
quelques mois plus tard elle décidé
malgré tout de sauver la vie avec l'aide
d'un médecin anonyme presque 22 heures
plus tard c'est l'association des
libertés civiles de la colombie
britannique qui a porté la cause devant
la cour suprême au nom de key carter et
de gloria telle à titre posthume car
depuis la longue bataille juridique
entamée
carter a obtenu une aide au suicide en
suisse alors que gloria terreur qui
souffraient elles aussi de la maladie de
lou gehrig est finalement morte d'une
affection
il y a deux ans à nouveau les défenseurs
de la cause estime que c'est la charte
canadienne des droits et libertés qui
doit primer sur le code criminel car la
constitution canadienne garantit à tout
le monde
la sécurité de la personne après tout
ajoute george patterson
les temps ont changé il ya maintenant
plusieurs plusieurs états dans le monde
à houlé médicale à mourir existe ça fait
partie du système de soins de santé et
ça fonctionne bien
ainsi la belgique les pays bas les états
américains de washington de l'orégon et
dans une certaine mesure ceux du montana
du vermont et du nouveau-mexique
autorise le suicide assisté ou
l'euthanasie au canada sondé récemment
sur la question suivante doit-on
modifier le code criminel pour permettre
aux médecins d'aider certains patients à
mourir
une forte majorité de canadiens se
disent plutôt d'accord avec le concept
la cour suprême tranchera vendredi sur
deux aspects la législation fédérale qui
criminalise les médicale à mourir doit
elle être annulée et les provinces
peuvent elles promulguer des lois
autorisant l'aide médicale à mourir dans
ce cas si la réponse est évidente pour
l'association des libertés civiles qui a
la même position que le québec qui lui
s'est doté d'une loi sur les soins de
fin de vie les médicale à mourir relève
de
de l'autorité provinciale mais le
gouvernement fédéral n'en démord pas le
code criminel punit toute assistance au
suicide d'une peine pouvant atteindre 14
en prison donc fédérer qu'est ce qui va
se passer si la cour suprême tranche en
faveur du suicide assisté
mais en fait céline le fédéral ne serait
pas forcément obligé dans le cadre et
tout ça par une loi en fait il ya
précédent 88è la cour suprême du canada
à l'époque avait légalisé l'avortement
et avait demandé au parlement d'adopter
une loi pour encadrer tout le processus
or à ce jour ça n'a jamais été fait donc
ya pas de loi canadienne sur
l'avortement
et tout ça est laissé en fait au
jugement il ya l'évaluation des médecins
qui regarde chaque cas selon leur code
de déontologie
selon la santé ou encore le bien-être de
la patiente et pour le québec a
certainement plusieurs personnes qui se
posent la question qu'est ce que ça peut
changer mais en fait depuis le début le
québec soutient mordicus qu'il s'agit là
d'un problème d'ordre aussi de santé
dont on parle ici d'une compétence
provinciale le québec a adopté une loi
en 2014 ce sont les dire et redire la
loi sur les soins de fin de santé les
soins de fin de vie pardon donc là on
parle de vie et on parle de santé on
parle évidemment de tout ce qui est
soins palliatifs et dans certains cas un
recours au cas exceptionnel de suicide
assisté alors encore une fois le québec
dit c'est provincial parce que c'est la
santé dont québec va vraiment regarder
dès demain matin vers ottawa
quelle sera la deuxième réponse à cette
fameuse question
ce qui sera intéressant de surveiller
c'est que c'est pas la première fois que
la juge devant les mclaren agent chef
actuel se penche sur ce dossier là bas
c'est ça en fait elle était déjà en 93
elle siégeait déjà la cour suprême du
canada et à l'époque elle faisait partie
des juges dissidents qui avaient voté en
faveur de la cause de ce world reggae ce
dont il faudra voir demain évidemment
quel sera l'impact de sa présence dans
la décision parce que maintenant on le
sait elle siège comme la juge en chef
donc
réponse demain à 9 heures 45 à la cour
suprême du canada à ottawa c'est in
une décision très attendue merci
beaucoup frédéric vous en prie